c'était une délibération symbolique mais
saint quentin en yvelines a lancé jeudi
soir en conseil d'agglomération son
projet de territoire se planque des
barrages qui va être décomposé sur
l'année qui vient puisque nous avons un
rétroplanning qui va aller jusqu'en juin
2017 et il va y avoir toute une série
d'actions bien sûr avec tous les
partenaires de la ville que ce soit les
habitants bien sûr mais que ce soit
aussi les entreprises
que ce soit les associations que ce soit
en fait tous les partenaires dans tous
les domaines qui nous permettrons
effectivement de ressentir
comment ils souhaitent aussi le voir se
développer ce territoire parmi les
priorités des communes saint-quentinoise
le développement économique
l'amélioration des transports mais aussi
la création de nouveaux logements
le développement économique est une des
choses fondamentales mais il ya aussi le
bien-être des habitants ça veut dire le
haut niveau de l'habitat comment on va
faire on a aussi un grand sujet si le
transport des élus des communes de
gauche ont quitté le conseil
d'agglomération en désaccord avec la
majorité et la faire aurore bergé
comment on fait un projet commun quand
on travaille dans ces conditions là ça
c'est pas sérieux
il a des vrais vrais enjeux mais on a
ils sont en train de débattre là à
quelques communes quatre communes sont
sortis une partie des élus sont sortis
c'est pas sérieux alors que l'on aurait
vraiment besoin de se mettre tous autour
de la table
ça demande d'être respectés pour
l'instant n'est pas respectée saint
quentin en yvelines travaillera aussi
avec les autres intercommunalités le
projet de territoire vise le long terme
de 25 à 30 ans